und wir gehen zu einem anderen Thema das
neben den Energiepreisen momentan viele
in Deutschland bewegt nämlich die
Situation an der deutsch-polnischen
Grenze die Situation einer
deutsch-polnischen Grenze ist nach wie
vor dramatisch wir hatten alle
eigentlich gedacht dass bis Ende des
Monats den Marke von 3.000 Feststellung
von unerlaubt eingerissen an der
polnischen Grenze festgestellt werden
Tag aktuell gestern lag die Zahl der
Feststellung von unerlaubt eingereisten
die über Belarus nach Europa gekommen
sind an der deutsch-polnischen Grenze
bei 6.500 das ist alarmierend und wir
müssen uns jetzt dringend mal Gedanken
darüber machen nicht nur die
Grenzkontrollen endlich einzuführen an
der deutsch-polnischen Grenze sondern
vor allem uns Gedanken darüber machen
woran liegt es was drückt die Menschen
aus ihrem Heimatland weg und was zieht
die Menschen ins Zielland was in diesem
Fall orange Deutschland ist
ja also die deutsch-polnische Grenze
betrifft ja auch genau mein Wahlkreis
das meine Heimatregion und in der Tat
das sind schockierende Bilder die wieder
sehen auch die Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung ist sehr sehr schlecht aber
ich sage gleichzeitig muss man dieser
Tage auch erwähnen wenn wir dann jetzt
sehen dass Leute sich da irgendwie zur
Bürgerwehr aufschwingen ist das auch
etwas was irgendwie schockierend ist die
Antwort muss der Staat geben deswegen
ist es wichtig dass die Bundespolizei da
auch verstärkt wurde und ich wünsche mir
eins ich wünsche mir dass wir dann ein
klares Regime haben gegenüber auch
illegaler Migration aber Grenzkontrollen
können eigentlich in unserem Europa und
das glaube ich ist auch eine Lehre aus
Corona und aus den Debatten dort eher
die letzte Variante sein wir müssen es
an der Außengrenze zu Polen lösen und
wir müssen vor allem dem Lukaschenko an
der stelle jetzt mal das Werk legen das
ist das allerletzte das ist staatlich
organisierter Menschenhandel in der
Klarheit muss man sagen und da dürfen
wir uns nicht erpressbar machen lassen
aber die Situation in der Tat ich habe
das gehört von Leuten aus meinem
Wahlkreis schockierend wenn in den
Gemeinden dann
sich dort der Müll ansammelt irgendwie
die Leute streuen dort durch die Region
auch für die Polizisten mit denen ich
gesprochen habe enorme Belastungen die
Situation können wir so nicht hinnehmen
was ist mit den Bürgerwehren die sie da
erwähnt haben wo bilden die sich ja das
haben wir jetzt ja gesehen dieser eine
Fall aus Brandenburg wo diese
rechtsextreme Splitterpartei der dritte
Weg dort aufgerufen hat wirklich dort
eine Bürgerwehr zu gründen da wurden
irgendwie Rechtsextremisten und dubiose
Typen aus allen Ecken irgendwie dort
zusammengezogen sowas geht natürlich gar
nicht und bei alledem ich gehöre jetzt
ja auch nicht zu denen die da irgendwie
ein Blatt vor den Mund nehmen wenn es um
illegale Migration geht ich spreche das
klar an aber man darf diesen Typen nicht
das Wort reden ist mir in dem
Zusammenhang nur ganz wichtig bei aller
Härte muss man sagen da ist eine Grenze
erreicht und man kann jetzt nicht sich
da so verhalten wie dies machen das ist
Job der Polizei in unserem Rechtsstaat
und die müssen wir dafür unterstützen
die Polizei hier so zurückhaltend also
ich meine sie setzt sich sie sind ja
jemand der der vertritt hier law and
order und sie sagen wir müssen mal nach
den Gründen forschen also von mir aus
nach die Gründe die werden doch nicht
anders sein als 2015 da gibt es
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge denke mal zu auf
ohne denen jetzt das Wort zu reden die
solche Kritik üben das tun wir alle
nicht da gibt es diejenigen die fliehen
verflucht und Vertreibung fliehen und
dann gibt es vielleicht auch darunter
wäre auch ungewöhnlich wenn nicht ein
paar Kriminelle die es überall gibt auf
der Welt so und die wollen alle nicht
nach Polen sondern die wollen zumindest
aus weil ich der Berichte die wir
gesehen haben vor allen Dingen nach
Deutschland und wegen über den Umweg
Türkei viele kommen über den Umweg
Türkei den gegen den Weg den sie eins
über andere Routen gegangen sind und da
muss man doch sagen auch als Vertreter
der Polizei die Gründe sind doch
eigentlich relativ klar die Frage ist
doch was tut man dagegen jetzt haben sie
jetzt haben sie wunderschön angesprochen
die Push und die pull Faktoren Push
Faktor ganz klar die Zustände in den
Heimatländern der Menschen die nach
Europa kommen überhaupt gar keine Frage
sehr schwer außenpolitisch in den Griff
zu bekommen aber das geht doch viel
Milliarden Menschen die pullfaktoren
sind aber viel viel einfacher zu
bekämpfen warum möchten denn die
Migranten die nach Europa kommen nicht
in Polen bleiben nicht in Ungarn bleiben
nicht in Griechenland oder in Italien
warum möchten diese Menschen nach
Deutschland und da muss man ansetzen und
je weicher unsere Bundesregierung mit
dem Schutz auch der nationalen Grenzen
umgeht desto mehr wird das Regime
Lukaschenko unterstützt weil diese
sogenannten pullfaktoren eben bedeutet
das müsste dann sozusagen aus ihrer
Sicht sollten die Bundespolizisten die
Möglichkeit haben an der
deutsch-polnischen Grenze Flüchtlinge ja
abzuschieben gibt die die Bundespolizei
hat die Möglichkeit wenn diese Grenze
notifiziert ist also angemeldet beim bei
der Europäischen Kommission und vom
Status her gleichgesetzt ist mit einer
Außengrenze ich aber sollte das wirklich
sein weil da stelle ich mir auch die
Frage wir haben eben von diesen offenen
Grenzen in Europa im gelebt viele junge
Leute die sich für Europa interessieren
sagen ein Grund dafür warum uns die EU
wichtig ist sind diese offenen Grenzen
manche oder können sich natürlich daran
erinnern wie sie an jedem Grenzposten
selbst zu Österreich immer wieder
Kontrollen gab gab es dann auch während
der coronazeit das ist doch nichts was
wir wieder wollen wir haben seit 2015 an
der österreichischen Grenze
Grenzkontrollen das wird nur verdrängt
aber nicht in der Regie nein also
selbstverständlich aber nicht ich habe
von nichts anderem gesprochen
temporäre Grenzkontrollen sage ich nicht
wir wollen die Grenze schließen okay
sondern ich sage wir wollen kanalisieren
so wie es an der österreichischen Grenze
passiert und da führt die Bundespolizei
Sichtkontrollen durch und zieht sich die
Autos raus und sie wollen dürfen
wir nicht weil diese die Grenze nicht
motiviert ist bei der EU weil wir dort
lediglich grenzpolizeiliche Maßnahmen in
einem Korridor von 30 Kilometern treffen
dürfen aber auch nicht ein
beispielsweise eine Zurückweisung eine
Einreiseverweigerung oder eine
Zurückschiebung das dürfen wir an einer
Schengen binnengrenze nicht machen wenn
sie nicht notifiziert ist Österreich ist
notifiziert deshalb haben wir auch die
Befugnisse und machen das auch wenn
jemand der in Aal ist jetzt nicht in
einem Ausmaß dass man sagen könnte das
verändert wirklich viel ja also von oder
wenn Sie wenn Sie die Zahlen 2013 nicht
2015/2013 mit den Zahlen von heute
vergleichen dann werden sie schön
feststellen glasklar feststellen dass
der Trend die Entwicklung
auf 2015 die zuläuft beispielsweise ich
meine die Zurückführung also die Zahlen
die man dann liest wie viele Flüchtlinge
jetzt von der österreichischen Grenze
zurückgewiesen wurden die sind ja
lächerlich
die sind aus dem Grund es gibt
beifangkriminalität die man dadurch auch
fast natürlich auch identitäts
Feststellungen und ich glaube es ist
halt klar
sind wir an zwei 15 gerade dran also wie
ist die Dimension gerade dass man sagen
kann wir sind ganz weit entfernt oder
sind wir schon fast davor wir sind
verdammt nah dran weil wenn diese
Entwicklung so rasant weitergeht wie sie
jetzt in der letzten Woche Fahrt
aufgenommen
in der größten Krise sozusagen 215 sind
über 10.000 Menschen täglich nach
Deutschland so wie viel haben wir jetzt
haben wir jetzt haben wir einen Stand
von gestern seit August 6500
wenn man jetzt sozusagen vor 215 waren
muss man einmal sagen 12 15 sind jeden
Tag über 10.000 Menschen über den Rente
bekommen
zwei Wochen sind ja schon 3000 mehr 2013
hatten die Kollegen in Passau an der
österreichischen Grenze um täglich um
die 350 bis 400 täglich das haben wir in
Spitzenzeiten in Frankfurt oder heute
auch
die Entwicklung die geht dahin und ich
bin mir sehr sicher dass das Ganze
höchstens noch einen Monat hält und wir
dann die Zahlen aber dass wir 10.000 am
Tag erreichen also hat bei einem Respekt
wie soll das funktionieren also naja der
Luca Schenker der Luca Schenk oder
bringt jede Woche jede Woche mehrere
tausend Menschen nach Weißrussland wir
müssen natürlich gucken dass
Grundproblem ist natürlich dass der Luca
schenkko dass er im Prinzip wirklich als
Menschenhandel institutionalisiert der
verteilt Visa die Leute fliegen da nach
minskum sich dann zu uns auf den Weg zu
machen und da muss man aus meiner Sicht
jetzt eine Balance finden ich sage offen
auch als Abgeordneter denn in
grenzwahlkreis hat ich will nicht dass
diese Grenze zugemacht wird da sind
viele Grenzpendler das ist so die Region
ist da zusammengewachsen polnische Ärzte
in unseren Krankenhäusern ich will keine
festen Grenzkontrollen was ich aber will
ist wenn die Flüchtlinge dort
aufgegriffen werden dass dann auch eine
Identitätsfeststellung gemacht werden
kann dass auch Maßnahmen wie eine
Zurückschiebung oder eine Abschiebung
gemacht werden können weil heute ist das
Problem die wollen sich natürlich dann
teilweise bewusst finden lassen von der
Polizei um dann zu sagen jetzt stelle
ich kleinen Asylantrag und dann ist die
Frage wie geht man dann damit um dann
gibt es erstmals monatelange Verfahren
da finde ich müsste man eigentlich ein
klares Grenzregime haben und unser
Problem ist seit Jahren dass wir
natürlich die EU-Außengrenze nie mit den
eigentlich gewünschten Hotspots für
abschiebezentren geschaffen haben und
das ist das Grundproblem wir können doch
nicht hier um Europa um Deutschland
jetzt eine Mauer bauen wir sehen die
entsprechenden Erfolge bei Österreich
natürlich auch deshalb weil die
Österreicher davon profitieren was in
ihren Außengrenzen nur dann hat
Maßnahmen oder in Ungarn mit der Mauer
mit dem Zaun das nun gemacht worden ist
deswegen gibt es auch bei uns weniger
Aufgriffe natürlich und deswegen ist das
Kontrollieren auch ein bisschen
einfacher als es beispielsweise an der
deutsch-polnischen Grenze der Fall wäre
aber die Frage die wir uns stellen
müssen ist ob wir so ein Zaun nicht doch
tatsächlich brauchen an den Außengrenzen
der EU womöglich und was frontexte alles
tun soll endlich mal ins Werk setzen
das ist eine Frage die wir wirklich mal
erörtern sollten und auch beantworten
müssen das ist glaube ich das ist glaube
ich das Kernproblem Polen weigert sich
bis heute Frontex unterstützen zu lassen
ja
Frontex ist immer das Problem das haben
wir in den letzten Jahren in der
Innenpolitik gesehen alle verweisen dann
auf frontext und die europäische Lösung
oft zu Lasten unserer Bundespolizei
unsere Bundespolizisten dann zu Frontex
schicken wenn die im Zweifel den Vollzug
nicht hinbekommen